you're seeing on your screen the
wonderful mercedes martinez now don't
rearrange your life here it is not
friday as normal it is tuesday still
but we are debuting a new segment here
on the program with mercedes las vegas
now host of course
mixed 941 it's called rise and shine
highlighting a feel-good story mercedes
good morning tia what do you have on tap
well good morning john we're so excited
about this segment yes we want to bring
a smile to your face as you kick off the
day and i've got a great video for you
this morning the cavs family
they have their own youtube channel and
their daughter
shocked their dad when she picked the
music that they got to listen to
in the car check it out really daddy can
i just pull on my side
oh god come on boys about languages
[Music]
what am i saying
[Music]
[Music]
hey
her love for the late selena quintanilla
is just coming through
as she sings bitty bitty bum bum and
como la flor
by selena and as you can see she even
tries to get her dad to join in by
telling him to sing in spanish and she's
saying
she just feels it in her soul and you
gotta love that josh
i think that's fantastic i don't know
why dad was he seemed to
i don't know if he was shocked or
disappointed but she did that was
fantastic
she was killing it i mean she sounded so
good so
hopefully that puts a smile on your face
today yeah and then
just see what your kids choose for a
song as your go take them to school or
whatever this morning and if they
start to bust out some selena just let
it go just let it go it'll be fine it'll
sound great mercedes thank you for oh i
think mercedes might be frozen but
that's okay because we are wide awake
here
of course she'll be back with uh
trending stories on fridays she's on las
vegas now
right here on chelated3 mix 941 right
now she's not frozen on the radio as far
as i can tell